can we talk about tonight's new season
of Survivor it's the show's 40th season
and some of favorite winners are at war
yes they are remember Boston Rob and
amber they met have fell in love on
Survivor Allstars back in 2004 and now
they are back and talking about their
ride-or-die love with our back : how
long have you been together now we've
been married for 15 years just about so
a lot of people think that like you know
we were on Survivor 39 days and now we
got married but there was actually about
a year in between that we were engaged
and then yeah it'll be 15 years in April
in the way our relationship started out
is so different than what anybody ever
experiences with dating at all I mean
when you're on Survivor you can't even
brush your teeth you can't even brush
your hair you don't even change your
clothes so we didn't have this like
almost fake way to impress each other
all we had was literally our
conversations you know it just it was
the most real as it gets
the extent of like the courting what
better way to test a relationship than
to spend 39 days on a deserted island
fighting for your life and two million
dollars Robyn Tamara returned for
Survivor sportiest season and they are
up against past winners how far are you
willing to go in the other's expense to
win honestly like I want to win he wants
to win but if there's something I can do
to help out his game I'm willing to do
that you know I'm willing to take the
step back to to help out he's my husband
for goodness sakes and vice versa it
doesn't matter whose name is on the
check at the end of it so long as it's
in our joint account rooting them on the
couple's four daughters who one day hope
to follow in their parents survivor
footsteps they're already they're
already planning this oh yeah
I already have this minor obstacle
courses in the backyard they're in
training no Jeff Probst is back his host
he says the competition gets intense
from the moment feet hit the sand these
are experienced players they've all won
and all of them are saying I've never
felt this level of paranoia I've never
been this tired it's only been five
hours
[Music]